Little 'r' reform means empowering the
people who actually do the work to make
decisions about how the work is done. But
it also means that how reform is done
usually matters more than whether reform
is done. Let me give you a simple example:
More than ninety-nine percent of
America's teachers are usually rated as
"effective", even in places where most
children don't seem to be learning. What
do we do about this? Over the last five,
six years, Washington and lots of state
to adopt a new policies requiring the
principals observe teachers regularly,
using test scores to evaluate teachers.
You know what's happened? In most of
those places, 97 or 98 percent of
teachers are still rated effective! What's
going on? Principals don't have any
incentive to pick a fight with their
teachers; nobody really wants to get
tough minded; but what matters most is
how this stuff, at the end of the day,
gets done! That's the key! We need to
focus less on grand policy solutions and
more on asking, "What does it take to
make these policies actually work in
real schools for real kids?"
To learn more about my take on the promise of little
'r' reform, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.